um I am a Michael Jordan Zealot so so
you're it'll be very very difficult to
ever move me off of the position that
Michael is the greatest baseball
basketball player can you at least agree
that the only right answer to who's the
goat is him or LeBron
yes okay but I will also respect someone
who
puts Kareem in there Kareem would be the
only other one like if you're like if
you're like 85 and you're like but you
didn't see Kareem's son I think it's
I mean the go conversation we've kind of
you know done
ad nauseam and I absolutely respect
LeBron James and I think it's yeah it's
such a gift that we have been able to I
think we've taken for Advantage
sometimes I don't take him for granted
I'll tell you why I don't take him for
granted one because I'm a Heat fan so
like thank you LeBron but I was really
you know it was kind of my feelings
about the Clevelands era after the heat
but once he came to the Lakers I was
like
I'm gonna enjoy this right like I'm not
going to you're living in L.A yeah yeah
like and also he did what he wanted to
do and I'm not like I got championships
in Miami because of it and had it really
started my career in Miami right in a
great way because he decided to come to
the heat but I'm not going to to be that
person that was like man
I got an opportunity to watch Michael
Jordan but I just hated him so much I
just barely came to that with Steph
because I I like hate I like hate to I
hate the Warriors really I just because
I'm a die hard like I got a LeBron toy
right there I'm a die-hard Suns fan but
this the dark years as you know the dark
years have been dark recently yeah so
since the Suns have been absolutely
cheeks I've always just rooted for
whatever team LeBron was on so I [__]
I'm a Heat fan Cavaliers fan hate the
Lakers but rooted for the Lakers in the
bubble year you know but uh I just the
the LeBron Steph battles that's fair I
just saw so many fair weather Warrior
fans at the time I lived in Florida I
lived in Tampa and uh there was all of a
sudden in the middle of the State of
Florida there's all these Warrior fans
well people like to people like to root
for things that are fun yeah you know if
you're gonna if you're gonna get in on
the NBA like it's not bad he just gets
so much hate and I'm like he's such a
good guy he's never done a weirdo I
think LeBron is
I think he is the greatest superstar
that we have ever seen in the history of
sports for sure and possibly like ever
in the country when you think about the
fact that he was in high school high
school was famous in high school on
Sports Illustrated
coming from that to now being how old is
he now 40 39 39 yeah 39 years old played
for 21 years in the NBA
has zero blemishes personally he's yeah
what's his biggest controversy that he
made a big announcement that he was
going to play for a better organization
after the organization that had him for
seven years couldn't put another player
around him exactly what's his oh and by
the way raise
millions of dollars for a charity and
doing it that's crazy what's his big
controversy that he won't speak about
China
right that's it that's all I mean people
people make up [__] like I mean give me
a break this guy's impeccable he's
elevated everyone around him he has
raised a family like has an unbelievable
family life has represented the NBA for
20 years and been the face and the
criticism like it's
just take a step back it's remarkable
it's never been done you can look at any
Superstar we've ever had in sports in
music and entertainment and movies
you're just gonna fall apart at some
point it's just human nature yeah like
the fact that he hasn't with all the
scrutiny and hate that he constantly
gets could that be me couldn't be me
couldn't be me either